this car's qualities are immediately
apparent it's compact and nice and
nimble we soon discovered that with its
narrow turning circle of 9.8 meters the
skoda city go takes curve smoothly and
precisely
what's special about this city go its
second name is gtech the badge worn by
scotus with natural gas technology
the engine is very fuel efficient says
our car tester frank the skoda gtech
burns just 2.9 kilograms of natural gas
per 100 kilometers 400 kilometers
the gtech has a 5 gear transmission and
a 50 kilowatt engine the agile
runaround's low fuel consumption and 79
grams of co2 emissions per kilometer are
very good
the citigo is a nifty thrifty and
environmentally sound car
fog matin says this rather curvy stretch
demonstrates how directly the steering
responds
he says the seats are fairly hard but
still comfortable
he wishes they'd provide a bit more
lateral support but after all this car
wasn't designed for racing
the city goes exhaust pipe is not in the
rear but hidden under the driver's seat
of the underbody
if you drive the city go with an eye to
fuel efficiency a tank of natural gas
will take you up to 400 kilometers
scooter's sales manager in germany
gunterridel notes that even with an
average driving style burning natural
gas produces very low levels of soot and
co2 so the citigo gtech is very
environmentally friendly it's a
monovalent vehicle which means it's
designed to run entirely on natural gas
but the car does have a 10 liter
gasoline reserve
the natural gas engine sounds no
different from a gasoline or diesel
engine and the car's external appearance
is also indistinguishable from the
conventional city goes
you won't find a gtech logo on the car
either only the green script go on the
rear hints at the car's efficiency
access to both the gasoline and the
natural gas tank is under the same latch
the natural gas tank holds 12 kilograms
inside only the compressed natural gas
gauge in the speedometer tells you this
is a gtech
in our test car the dashboard and seats
are a bright and friendly beige
frank martin says the city goes shows
that even a sub compact can offer enough
space for big people he himself is 1.91
meters tall but sits fairly comfortably
with enough leg and headroom that means
a long drive and this small car is no
hardship
the trunk is big enough for everyday use
the trunk has about 216 liters of
storage space not exactly a freight
specialist but certainly enough for a
shopping trip and maybe a weekend trip
away for two
skoda integrated the natural gas tanks
in the car's underbody leaving no space
for a spare tire but most city drivers
can live with that
frank says this car is perfectly
adequate for everyday users
in germany the skoda citigo gtx starts
at just over 13 000 euros